and then the other title company pick up
the check the first time this happened
it was like it was a life-changing
moment you have a listen to how this
deal plays out this is what wholesale I
just hug that your emotions dude look I
emailed the buyer and all three of my
partners and I was like please tell me
these numbers and not as bad as I think
they're all four of them do those are
terrible
then the NOI they said was 104 turned
out to be like 70 and that decreases the
value a lot she just got something
turned on a 50k offer because the guy
came close for two months we said hey
we'll give you twenty two thousand will
close in ten days yeah
which is literally unheard you go to an
apartment or say a house in Phoenix
they're asking two thousand a month say
he'll give you two thousand a month as
long as you let me rent about an Airbnb
and he'll make five thousand dollars a
month I think most beautiful thing is
that you can always you can do whatever
you want you can always change your
story and there's no limits boom what's
up everyone welcome to simulation I'm
your host Alan sake on we are now going
to be talking about real estate
we have Austin cost joining us on the
show what's up Austin Allen how're you
doing here coming back on it was great
yeah usually I know when you're coming
to town and you just hit me with the
text couple couple days ago and I was
like let's go looks I know we did this a
couple months ago so yeah last time we
think he's an uary I think I was going
back from Christmas and then yeah that's
when you're in town that was when the
round one was and you were progressing
in your entrepreneurial endeavor and now
we're gonna be unpacking the progress
I'm pumped for this if those are done'
austin's background he's a real estate
investor focused on locating off market
properties managing short and long-term
rentals and investing into long term
value at apartment complexes you can
find the links in the bio below to mehta
stone capcom we buy home sioux falls
calm and top-tier mg calm all right
awesome let's start things off with one
of our favorite questions to ask our
guests what are your thoughts on the
direction of our world yeah good
question I knew the song something like
this is gonna be thrown my way
I would say I just have some thoughts
just on the political climate because
that obviously it takes everyone's
talking about it and my biggest fear is
I think it's it's becoming at least in
America where you know there's there's
so much divide it's becoming it's
becoming embarrassing to the fact that
we're not even talking about real issues
in this country anymore because it's
election season so literally from now
until election season it's literally
gonna be one side trying to take down
the other side not talking about any
issues it's just gonna be total chaos
and it's gonna play into trump and then
trump's gonna get reelected in my
opinion by a landslide and then it's
gonna be four more years of chaos and
then I don't know I it's it's it's very
it's a time where there's a lot of
uncertainty and I think it's interesting
just to kind of analyze because then
there's all been there's stuff going on
internationally I try not to pay
attention too much to all that stuff
just because I mean we're entrepreneurs
we got to be laser focused on what we're
doing but I mean I don't know sometimes
the news you just turn on the news and
it's just like what's going on here I
don't know sense making mechanism for
civilization is so important and the
tribalism and echo chambers and
cognitive ease and all the biases that
we have and algorithms and news feeds
that exist right now and the corrupted
business plans focused on the attention
economy all of these things are playing
out into a wrecking of our sense making
mechanism that we need we need to be
able to make sense of the existing
social fabric and how to make it better
when you have polarized perspectives on
given issues that are just trying to
hurt other people rather than actually
listen to each other and trying to make
progress we have a very sensitive time
ahead of us and if we want to make the
change we need to work on that sense
making mechanism I completely agree and
they
what do you think about the media part
of it like did you see the article that
the New York Times is like they hired a
team just to focus on like the Russia
investigation and now that that's gone
now they have a brand new team just
trying to talk about Trump's racism so
like that's not even that's not
reporting would you agree like that's I
think that's the most dangerous part is
that like the media is becoming
ridiculous like especially the
mainstream media like we keep hearing it
from Trump but it's like I mean you
literally can't trust its opinions it's
it's not reporting it's mostly opinions
and they don't tell you that it's an
opinion article either they it's just
like I mean that mainstream media is
also being has some gatekeepers it's
called kind of like the gated
institutional narrative that kind of
protects whatever stories are being
distributed around the planet that's why
independent media is actually really
really important and for people to fund
independent media is critical right now
so what you can do is you can focus on a
sense-making mechanism and you can focus
on trying to find ways to impact
yourself your own divine connection to
source and work on yourself and then
that immediately affects your family
your community your entire social fabric
around you so it really starts from
within and then that usually catalyze a
significant change around the world but
it has to start from within and it also
has to start also from realization that
some of the things outside of us need to
be updated from its archaic fabrics okay
let's do we're you know let's do where
we've been going in the last nine months
so where have things what's transpired
for you and the guys in last nine months
yeah so I think nine months yeah so
those in January pills when we wheat me
and Dylan in another partner we had just
gotten started just kind of wholesaling
finding off market properties for
investors just that process we hadn't we
had
made a deal or talked about that for a
little bit yeah market properties and
wholesaling
yep so properties that are not listed on
the market yeah owners that want to just
get rid of their homes and they just
decide but they don't want to list it
they just want to work with someone yeah
well I'll give you an example I mean say
there's a $200,000 house somebody's
lived in for you know 20 years nan good
shape at all like it would be worth two
hundred thousand if it was like this
house like kept up nice and clean then
it could it can be listed but a lot of
these people don't don't take care of it
they would have to put in money before
they could even list it or try to sell
it as is but then pay realtor fees
anyways so a lot of times they'll just
go hey we don't want to we don't want to
use realtor we just want you to give us
an offer we want to close as quickly as
possible
can you do that and they a lot of times
they even say like we're willing to take
a substantial discount so and the reason
this is so valuable is because I wrote
when I got into real estate I tried to
find all my deals online Zillow all
these different spots and I quickly
realized you cannot find good like fix
and flips good rentals because maybe
it's probably just because it's in a
good market right now but everything so
there's so many deals out there that
people are selling for higher prices so
there's not that many deals on market so
these investors that are you know hoping
that I can find these deals there
they're like starving for deals like
right now I have way more buyers and
deals right now because no one can find
good deals so that's where it becomes a
very valuable thing and then it's
obviously the better deals you find the
better you get paid for it so obviously
if you provide a service you're going
get paid for it but again are you doing
with the property you have to buy it if
it's a $200,000 property you buy for
what a hundred thousand yeah and then
you have to do some sort of renovating
to it in order for it to be able to go
on market and be sold I'll give you
examples I'll give an example if the
first deal we actually closed so we got
a lead we hired a cold caller because at
this time we're in state we're at State
Farm we just kind of like prospect
throughout the day we were talking about
that so we actually hired a cold caller
from the Philippines for like eight
bucks an hour
and so we got her a list of like
thousand and she got this lead and then
after work called the guy long story
short his dad died 10 years ago as his
dad's house it's vacant now in Baltic
South Dakota small town in North and
South Dakota and he's been trying to he
wanted to like renovate it his life
happened you know I could never came
around to it so he's like I just want to
get rid of it he's that need 30,000 for
it I'd like that some property back
taxes Yetta Yetta went out there told
him to give you 30 you know is there any
wiggle room he said yeah definitely just
give me an offer and then I said all
right you know best we can do is 15 yet
he got a long story short we got it
under contract so signed a purchase
agreement between me and the seller you
know his name's Ryan and then for it was
$17,500 a contract for agreement that I
was gonna I would buy it from him
for seventeen thousand five hundred
dollars but I have the option to assign
this contract to another buyer so I have
the option I can do either at this point
so once I get into the contract I
actually already had a buyer who said
he'd pay 25 for it okay so I called the
buyer said hey got under contract what's
the best you can do for various reasons
we he'll he agreed for twenty three five
so assigned it to him twenty three five
the difference between that what is that
5500 66.6 the difference of that so I
think so I sent both of those documents
to the title company they do all the
work at closing I don't even have to
show up the closing what was this last
part you sent its buying agreement
you're buying it for seventeen five from
the owner
yep the buying agreement says in the
contract that you can then assign the
whole country the whole contract to
another buyer that's gonna be buying it
from you
yep okay and they're buying for twenty
three five yep okay
you gave that they agree to that that
everyone's agreed on that so does this
the seller doesn't even need to know
that you're doing this other part of it
she doesn't need to he doesn't need to
know I told him just cuz I'd like to be
transparent because I think at the title
company they can probably see I I don't
know I actually don't know this for sure
if they can see the price that I signed
it for yeah but I just told him I said
hey I got a buyer that would like sis he
asked if he could pay me a fee if he
could get the deal they've never had an
issue with it but to your point yeah
like so I got that one contract and they
got the assignment contract was just
different contracts sent both contracts
to the type of companies of the title
company which does like title search
they're the ones that make it official
they're the ones that actually so and
then I at closing the seller and end
buyer they're the ones that actually
show up to the title company I don't and
once once both parties signed getty
calls new year's emails me says hey your
checks ready can come pick it up and
then go the title company pick up the
check the first time this happened it
was like it was a life-changing moment
because like I thought I was so
intimidated by the whole process I
didn't think he would do it so many
things came up through this title
process sounds like is you know or need
to get any sort of no licensing in order
to pair together a seller with a buyer
you don't need it it's the only way to
get paid for broker and real estate
without a license and I actually had to
talk to the South Dakota real estate
commission because bitter agent actually
called me and he said he's gonna report
me because I you have to have a license
and I was like go for it because I knew
I did I knew I didn't like I even had a
lawyer telling me it was illegal but I
knew it wasn't so real estate commission
called me up and I just told him exactly
what I was doing and he and it's funny
cuz he's like yeah technically you're
right because the that that specific
issue has never been addressed in the
South Dakota law you know I was like
sounds good so let me know if I have any
other issues and I haven't heard from
him since and I was good I was gonna
like call up that agent not worth it and
this is called then just
just buying and selling off market
properties is what this is called yeah
it's cold wholesale real estate no
ceiling wholesale real estate why is the
word wholesaler used well I think I mean
you can hold sell anything you actually
just buying discount things you buy this
kind of on just sounded things and
selling them yeah wholesale yeah okay
that's not off market disc deeply
discounted investment property deeply
discounted properties because thing
about this few mile this
I mean if Apple stocks $100 you can't
buy from 50 but technically real said
you can if the seller agrees to it so
the rights of the seller of the stock
dust2 know Apple could never allow that
insider trading illegal if someone owns
Apple stock if they're once I sell it on
the stock market for for a disc because
they themselves just want to so they
think they would have to gift it I think
they're gifted cuz you can't he doesn't
even cut up if you if you didn't know
who the buyer was the vendor would be
different than if you knew who the buyer
was and you were selling it under even
then I see where this is all going that
there are likely rules and regulations
here because you can't sell under the
under the current bid Craig yeah thanks
for it yeah and that's why that's why
it's so cool cuz like it's the only
asset you can actually buy like
legitimately discounted like we well you
could buy cars or you could buy yeah I
not tell you how other you would listed
watches or boats or planes or you know
those are depreciating yeah exactly you
can't really buy an appreciating asset
discounted you true some reals except a
real estate in like maybe an old call
you're gonna see like yeah like some of
those cars they appreciate or like an
old just an old like vintage item that
could appreciate a penny on the switch
that was yeah okay but these are like
bigger deals you can get six thousand
books okay so how did you should give
the person in the Philippines that was
doing the calling identified the person
that wanted to sell it that was the that
was the first identification
yep so we got a list from actually a
different VA a virtual assistant got me
a list of like a thousand in Minnehaha
County which is where Sioux Falls is
that a thousand a list of a thousand
properties where it absentee owners
which means the owners do not live at
the property so it's either vacant it's
a rental
or that second house whatever they don't
live there and I just have this person
find this list so it's all public record
but I will say in some counties it's a
little bit set in some counties it's
harder than others like it's harder and
South Dakota like we're moving to
Arizona and down in Arizona a title
company will give us all these lists for
free but in South Dakota it's actually
pretty hard to get some of these so why
can you do what you're gonna do in
Arizona it's actually easier but a lot
more competition okay so buying and
selling that's what I'll start Alex it's
also also started in Phoenix all the
gurus aren't gurus like that the
teachers and teachers all there's big
big players are in Phoenix so like like
a good spread in South to get like the
difference that's the Simon for you good
ones 10,000 South Dakota there's 50,000
so happening all the time in Phoenix
because people are you rational down
there bigger markets they just get
irrational especially good in a gift
economy so it's gonna be it's gonna be
but there's a lot more competition so
we're still we're gonna see we're gonna
see how it is because I like Sioux Falls
because there's not that much
competition I know the market very well
now I'm going down there totally new
market but you're have a little bit of
tentacles you have tentacles and Sioux
Falls that are you staying here some of
your team is gonna be saying yeah okay
exactly okay and then how did you find
the buyer for this first one that you're
giving us an example of so right we
started out we had to find buyers before
we started looking for deals we knew we
had to get a buyer because if you get a
deal they were to say if you get a good
enough deal you'll find a buyer but I
was like I want I want some buyers so
all I did was we created a website and
it's there's a company called carrot
that specializes in websites for real
estate investors because you know what I
can often that is like the clickfunnels
like you click here to get my free ebook
yeah and then you click get free e-book
but then they have you know
so my website had a similar opt-in page
click here to get local off market real
estate properties and then put that on
literally Craigslist and within the
first prior two weeks had like 40 buyers
and then that that channel kind of cool
off a little bit both and then just some
networking go to meetings and you find
people you talk about what you deal on
the golf course I've gotten cash buyers
but the first batch of them for this
deal the first batch was a from that
online ad that I put and and then I
actually met up them quite a few times
before the deal so that's the best a big
thing like some people say you need par
buyers but I think you need you know
some good ones just a few good yes
they're actually can close and then the
idea would be you hopefully don't invest
like 600 hours into this close because
then you'd only be making 10 bucks an
hour yeah and that would love yeah maybe
eventually we'll talk about like some of
the some of the failures because a
couple months ago I invested so much
time into this massive deal that was
gonna pay us a lot of money fell through
right at the end and that we spent so
much time that our pipeline wasn't very
full so we're still recovering from that
like months that we thought these two
deals and big deals were both gonna
close and it was a murder it was a shot
to the heart like we were like but I
think it happened for us because we were
getting to learn because we were like
dude this is easy we're gonna side deals
a role and we had like five in the
pipeline were just like this is too easy
so I think it did huh below us it
brought us back to zero and now we're
like now we're back in the hungry mode
but I think you need a we are starting
out I think that you need to get like
that punch though to the face that come
to my house yeah
because if my dad was like Jesus looks
too easy I like five feels to like the
universe is like yeah it's life's not
this yeah but teaches you a lot it's all
lessons Landon says so then walk us
through what the followed the next deals
were yep so there was a there was one
deal that it was actually a you're gonna
love this
so we got a call Dylan got a call said
hey saw your advertisement I like to
summer house to you what I've didn't ask
any questions just went over there the
next day and marathon and they said they
I quote from the that one of the husband
yeah I've been I Drive by your sign to
your billboard every day and I just
thought I'd finally give it a try in my
mind we don't have a billboard but there
is somebody that doesn't a billboard we
buy houses Sioux Falls were we buy home
Sioux Falls so we have to leave just not
gonna say yeah it's just like I looked
at Dylan I was just like yeah but like I
think I mean but the situation was the
higher 85,000 our house where is it
located
cliff Avenue over by Sioux Falls you
know where it's it what's the
intersection it's uh 57 cliff 50 cent a
little bit a little bit north from there
okay it but it's on cliff yeah so it did
sell for like 190 the year before so
she's like hey we need to get out of
this we'll just take the woods path the
mortgage we can pay off the mortgage
this is what it's at what's your offer
we offered her like 140 and she accepted
it and then we assigned it to one of my
good cash buyers for 149 oz does a good
one and then congrats goes to that was
like right after so I was like okay and
then and how do you where this where is
the the trusted third party that says
that this is what was that person call
the in the title company tight in this
that there's multiple title companies
and you have to pick one that's trust
theater so yeah we didn't talk about
that much and that was actually crucial
because before I even started
deels I needed a title company they
could actually execute the deal
and since Sioux Falls they all the new
trends just get to South Dakota last it
seems like that most these people had
never even heard of wholesaling like
didn't think you could do it thought it
was illegal so I had to call every
single all five tunnel companies in
Sioux Falls finally one of them said
that they could do it but I had to talk
to the president because he's the only
one that deals with it so I it took me a
week I've kept calling this guy like I'd
yet like I'm getting closer to a deal I
need to know finally call me back at
work we had an hour convo told me all
this stuff he said yep you can do it
whenever you come across these just make
sure you email it to me because I'm the
only one that knows how to do it so he
liked the first deal she knew I have so
many screw-ups and he just helped me
through it he's like no I'll fix this
not a big deal so he was that was
crucial because like what were the
screw-ups in that like we didn't like
the contract just little things like
whoo-hoo so one of a big thing that we
one of our big selling points is that we
pay all the closing costs like what if
we say 135 you're getting 135 no matter
what in the first deal I didn't like I
said buyer to pay all closing costs but
there was a couple cost was a title
insurance fee and one other fee I
thought it was and I didn't specify so
right before closing he had to call me
he's like hey who's supposed to pay
these fees and I was like put buyer yet
areata
so that he fixed that right last minute
yeah so some of those fees like a grand
or two yes usually closing costs if
there's no real term well probably only
like three to five percent of the total
purchase but I mean you know 150,000 was
so it was a you know it's decent amount
so but it's I think it's more so I mean
they're saving $3,000 it's more about
the hassle because we can close quicker
but yeah I mean the title company is
crucial so that one went well and
there's a couple more deals and then
really the big one they really just kind
of took off everything I don't I don't
know if we want to get into like the
apartments but this is kind of how to do
it now this is kind of how this is how
the apartment that all started I had a
deal it was one of my like my third deal
I sent it to all my cash buyers
and one of them called me left me a
voicemail over the weekend and I don't
know I was like him must be interested
called him up and he goes hey I'm
actually not interesting the property
because I can't buy anything else until
you know I sell my apartment that I have
in Iowa and I was like what I was like
oh I was like really what kind of
partner do you have he's like 48 units
you know it's cats its it brings in the
aniline net operating income which is
where that's how you value anything he's
like in a whi hundred four thousand you
know we could probably you know six
hundred thousand we could probably sell
it to you for and I was just like wow I
cuz I analyzed enough big deals where I
knew I don't know a lot about that yet
cuz I'm bought one but I knew those
numbers were absurd net operating income
after all expenses of salvaging the
property size debt red - the debt - if
there's a if there's debt if there's a
loan on it it's - that okay so the debt
service and then but obviously six
hundred thousand for 48 units it's a
small town Iowa and they own equ only
got like five hundred a month four fifty
let's here's the problem because analyze
big one hundred foot four thousand and I
had a buyer who was like for sure let's
do that right now let's get this going
and then I in it and then he's like you
know why don't we just go in it together
like you know why don't we do it joint
venture if you can raise some cash you
know then we can do it that way and I
was like holy [ __ ] and I hope my
long-term vision was always to find
apartments bigger deals and then have
investors yeah reversing income
investors buy into the deal I manage the
whole deal again idiotic yeah that's
apartments indication but I harm in
synthetic well this is the case when you
get investors to come on to go into the
purchase of an apartment complex and you
manage the whole thing including the
person that manages the actual property
afterward and then you pay out the
investors a portion and you just take
the
management fee of this yeah your process
is typically you know typically fee of
ten investors each in at ten percent you
want to be one of those at ten percent
because you you don't have to do this
way but you want your money aligned with
their money because I mean think about
it if this guy I don't want to invest it
you know but so and I knew that was that
that was long in but I didn't think I
could get there that fast and then some
like holy cow I could do this right now
so I called the Pilar I was like how do
I do this yada yada 20k legal fees to
get all these documents but he's like
it's doable for sure we ended up we
ended up where he just wanted to he just
wanted to pay me 25 K just to do the
deal himself so I was gonna wholesale it
I I had it under contract 575 he was
gonna pay 600 as long as because we were
gonna do a non-refundable earnest
deposit usually when you get into an
apartment deal there's so much due
diligence where it's like within 30 days
you can back out get all your money back
but these guys wanted to do like since
they were giving us such a big discount
they want to realize to do like $10,000
non-refundable deposit you know I was
like okay well I haven't seen your
numbers confirmed so if we can do that
then we'll firstly do that so it's like
yeah no problem so it sounds like with
all the numbers and I was like alright
this last thing that we're gonna get
this deal closed everyone's on board
title companies on board everyone was
ready to go in this took up a month of
my time I drove down to Cherokee Iowa
visited the whole property talk two
month talk yeah
back-and-forth talk to these guys back
and forth like every day for a month and
finally and then I and then I looked at
the numbers I was on the golf course and
I got my email and I probably looked at
it for like five seconds and they didn't
look as good as I thought so I emailed
like well I emailed the buyer and all
three of my partners and I was like
please tell me these numbers are not as
bad as I think they're all four of them
dude those are terrible and then so the
NOI they said was 104 turned out to be
like 70 and that decreases the value a
lot so basically the deal fell through
told the told the guy like hey you lied
to me I mean I'm sorry and then I never
heard from again so I took about
freaking month and I was you all
a lot learned a lot but that was 25
grand you were hoping to make and I
thought and I thought it was there
thought it was there I was like you
learned a lot about apartment
syndication which you're Italian oh
that's interesting these like lessons
from this higher the university is
always throws you lessons it's it's
crazy
you gotta see them as lessons to learn
from them it's all that respect to me
everything's coming at us but it's like
how do you proceed what okay yeah I like
that it's all but these things are
harming you or hurting you or they there
to teach you and create Astaire's
earlier I think the best uh I think the
best quote was like life doesn't happen
to us happens for if I didn't see that
until recently it's like if you just
simply think about if everything
anything happens live if you always know
what that happened anything like what
did it teach me like yeah dude my
perspective is true so much yeah like
doubt that's what we did cuz like this
fell through and Dylan goes dude don't
work don't worry Austin's happen for us
I was like yep let's go like sit action
like legitimately helps you okay so what
are the other upcoming deals so we we're
cool right now we're actually not whole
selling a deal because me and two
partners are moving down to Phoenix so
we don't want to just leave everything
we've built in Sioux Falls so my good
buddy from college Ethan he's moving up
to Sioux Falls and basically the
agreement was you know we're not gonna
like pay masala we'll give him a
percentage of the holes like of like the
entity and we'll buy him a duplex so he
doesn't have to pay for rent so
basically we're getting my duplex this
is this is a kind of universe type thing
too because it was coming down to the
wire I couldn't I was trying to find a
duplex I was like I was trying to I
wasn't I was not gonna look online
because a big thing with duplexes
if you're gonna live in one side is
you've got to make sure that the side
you're living on is smaller or it
doesn't have to be but like you want to
make sure that the other side can pay
the mortgage
yeah so you can live for free and I
happen to cold call this guy like
wholesaling and he wasn't taking me
seriously I talked this guy probably 20
minutes he thought it was just [ __ ]
and finally I
like I was persisting I was like Chris I
I needed my duplex I'm not effing around
I I would love to buy this duplex
already she's my buyer and finally he's
like yeah I mean yada yada and we
finally agreed in the price and we're
actually gonna like he's gonna be things
gonna live in like this bottom unit it's
one bed one bath and the top unit is
like the whole house so it's like four
beds two baths can probably get 1,400 a
month and our mortgages give me about
eight oh nine yeah that's huge so it's
gonna be so you've ever got a thousand
like we're not gonna you know yeah it's
like that's that's what Victoria I
annoyed I I ignore my friends so much
about this it's like why would you eat
why would you pay rent or buy a house
when you could just buy duplex is it for
free that's my two cents on real stakes
it just makes too much sense
let's go San Francisco it's kind of hard
because it holds on San Francisco I
wonder what California is not only your
pricing but also the regulations and
rules that are there there's these like
in-law units and things like that
oh I think if you wanted to maybe live
in one of those and rent the house
things like that sort of how this one is
yeah that's right and also just all the
stuff that we're gonna talk about their
B&B there are a lot of crackdowns that
are going on right now yeah a lot of
people are kind of pissed off at people
for just buying houses and just air beam
being them and increasing really yeah
yeah I mean it's interesting the
comparison between how hotels are trying
to like get people mad at Airbnb so
hotels can try and keep more of the
market share meanwhile the it's it's
interesting that it is being
democratized to people being able to you
know sleep in extra rooms and stuff like
that that's totally cool at the same
time it's like there are artists and
entrepreneurs that are trying to be
creative in these metropolis and they
can't afford to live there because
people are buying second third fourth
fifth homes and just trying to rent seek
and rent seeking is a major problem in
real estate it basically came down to
you are literally adding no value to the
economy all you're doing is increasing
the price
of the rent at that property and then
what you're doing is you're making it
harder for artists or entrepreneurs or
other leaders that are coming through
that are trying to make value additions
to the metropolis area into the world
you're making it harder for them and
you're actually also kicking out other
people that live in those areas that can
no longer afford those prices so there's
got to be some sort of a deal of balance
here where we do weigh a let people go
and do cool things like Airbnb but if
you're really trying to make money bring
something of value into the world make
an idea happen come to fruition
don't just jack up prices or buy
properties just to jack up prices so
that you can try and make money on that
people do that because it's easy but
what they're doing is they're literally
hurting creativity yeah I would agree
with that
I mean it's but I mean real estate I
guess there's there's not it's pretty
cut and dry it's just capitalist thing I
kind of know to me about the rent
seeking you know if you're not really
adding value and that's why I feel like
if you're gonna be real say you really
do gotta have a clear purpose of why
you're in real estate because I think
you know I think I want to change my
purpose is like I think investing though
it's better way than investing in 401k I
think it's the best investment you can
make
but I don't think enough people want to
do it because I don't know how to do it
and I want to provide that vehicle so
then do it how would someone ethically
invest into real estate without rent
seeking that type of thing um well I
would say I don't know but I would say
everyone needs to invest in something to
grow their money so I mean the moral
thing I guess
why do you invest in bonds I don't know
like I know what you're saying but but
at the same point people who have money
they need to preserve their money
because they don't want to lose it and I
know we can go back and forth on that
but as far as I mean investing in real
estate for the moral is that
like in whatever whatever thing that's
being invested into is in a sense are
you reshaping rules and regulations to
propagate your own market advantage or
are you trying to invest in things that
can then unleash the creative potential
of other people from around the world
I think the see I think I think that I
think once you get into development I
think that's where you can get into the
creativity where you can develop things
for specific businesses stuff like that
okay we can can we can read this and
that's it that's an interesting question
I wanna answer it cuz I mean two tough
one
it's ethics its meshes ethics with chasm
is that this is investing or is it
unethical I mean it's not it's not
unethical to invest in real estate it's
probably more about this whole idea of
rent seeking because that's a term that
I ever knew it's a really important term
this is something that happens in
California and it happens everywhere
around the world now just if you have
money what you do is you go and
potentially buy a second property and
then you don't live in that property but
what you've done is you bought a
property that you then do things like
just say hey the rates in this general
metropolis are around let's say three
thousand dollars a month for this house
and so what I'm gonna do is I'm just
gonna put this house up on the market
for that amount of money once that's
cranking and making me money I'm gonna
buy another house in the metropolis put
that one up for three as well over time
I'm gonna see my neighbors that put a
house up for three five I'm gonna start
putting mine up for three five I'm gonna
do my best to try and get the tenants
the least amount of Rights possible so
that I can most easily and effectively
increase the rent to thirty five hundred
that extra five hundred a month is so
meaningful to me being a
multi-millionaire it's so important for
me to get the extra five hundred a month
whereas literally for a tenant that is
that has if it's a four bedroom unit
that each one of them is paying about a
thousand bucks a month or so those four
people that are living there likely
don't even have the extra $500 per 2
foot for a bill for their car or bills
their health
or anything so there really has to be a
deep amount of empathy that goes from
people that are owning these properties
and people that are renting them
I think the free market determines that
though because you can't just like raise
it and I mean because people will go
somewhere else but I think with the real
estate though like you are provided
you're providing something legitimate
like you're providing housing especially
if you're doing Airbnb like you're
providing a nice vacation around with
it's better than a resort something in
that aspect I mean there's a lot of
nuance on this topic every but there
really is yeah I mean you're right
because I know what you're saying - well
you also you also have different
perspectives you live in literally the
highest rent in the world one of them
yeah but at the same time the people
that own the properties they can't just
don't leave isn't an increasing is
because that other people are you know
there's so much nuance on this subject
yes okay so let's so take us through the
the the most recent steps as you've been
deciding to leave to also focus on the
Tempe area in Arizona so dia take us to
this time period now oh yeah so it's
been a it's been an interesting
transition and we're actually so we
haven't really talked about it but me
and to my partner's Brady and Dylan
we're moving down to Phoenix
Brady he's already there me and don't
leave next Monday and we're initially
gonna do it in June but we have some we
had that's when our first couple deals
started rolling and we were just just
way too much going on we there's no way
we were gonna be able to leave so we
pushed it back like I said because we
don't want to just up and leave all the
things connections we've made so since
then the transition really has been
getting Arden our new partner Ethan a
duplex which take up a lot of my time
yes she's a lot of my time painful
itself which is great let's release him
up to do the Sioux Falls side of the
wholesale well there's gonna be a lot of
we're gonna have to train him because
he's been working his job so like
Dylan's been he's done a big guide of
like training guide for him which will
be good
people that you like because now we're
doing standard operating procedures I
didn't even know that was a thing in
business which is embarrassing
because like you got to be able to if I
died somebody's got to pick up exactly
what I'm doing
ya know how to do it so we've been
developing that so that like Ethan knows
what to do so that he can kind of like I
mean obviously we're gonna help him but
so he can kind of run on his own up here
and then and then just kind of getting
into the kind of repeating what we did
have done in the Phoenix market so
that's kind of where we're at now big
transition mode this week it's kind of
gonna be like moving moving down getting
out anything pacts but yeah it's been
it's been a process this summer's been
literally the most craziest summer I
learned the most failed the most total
deals so far just three total of 25 km
25k three deals and what was the last
deal so there was that house on cliff
57th the Baltic house they first
mentioned was there I wasn't think what
was this deal I'll think of it when I
tell you about this other deal because
there's no there's this other big deal
that fell through when that apartment
deal fell through so that was a big
dagger oh this one okay this one was a
their six year old couple their son has
been living there paying them like cheap
rent for like ten years
stop paying rent just wanted to get rid
of it that one took a while at probably
a month but we bought it for 45
where was it huh by Whittier so like
nobody would you know which part of
Sioux Falls actually a couple blocks
east of downtown yeah
visiting 45 says listen to this this is
crazy
subtle cheap isn't it yeah but listen
how the deal plays out okay this is what
wholesale I just tugs at your emotions
nude so 45 and I had a buyer lined up at
65 signed a contract 65 contingent on
inspection and I was just a little
worried about that I was like I mean
obviously you can tell this is pre
rundown the heat but you just wanted to
like run get it like rent ready and just
keep running it out like a slumlord
which I don't like that
I hate that kind of stuff what do you
see what I'm saying that's right see
that's what was thought I don't you if
you're not good if you're not giving
them a good players literally oh but
we're gonna buy a property so that you
can then rent it
oh I get hope this isn't stopped at a
lonesome thing I get it but it's also
very very very this line of nuance here
is really tight it is it's really I
think the Pens out so what if your give
him a good place to live that's what
Jimmy oh that's a little human sorry all
right let's continue yes please okay so
so it's out of here 65 and I'm like holy
cow a 20k and then much attention on the
special continue inspector yeah it's bad
feeling I was like this is on a Friday I
was like oh yeah so that in Monday
morning get a text deals deals done
inspection foundation issues and I'm
just like dude you saw these issues like
it's for that's why it's 65 like it's
worth 150 if you actually fix everything
but he don't want to she backed out and
at this point I had three days so when
you sign one of these purchase
agreements there's there's a there's
like a time period like a dude Dale just
where I can back out and I only have
three days or two days it was a Monday
by the end of Wednesday's the last time
I could back out else I had to buy it
for forty five thousand so like so I'm
like oh my god I have literally the rest
of today Tuesday to find a new buyer so
I emailed all my buyers and I called a
couple of them and I said hey I got a
deal somebody just had on conflict 65
I'm willing to take a substantial
discount as low as 48 thousand if we can
get a quick close cuz at that point I
just wanted to like make sure that I
didn't screw over the seller start
screwing the sellers they're all
companies that's bad yeah that's what
the Real Estate Commission does not want
so if you screw that's a big thing
because they're trying protecting the
sellers so as in the seller already
believes that you're able to take care
of it exactly so that's what it sounds
like and I could have bought it but I
really wanted it's too much work so much
work is a big fix of a project and then
it happens so so I was on Monday that
previous Saturday I was up in Brookings
and a baseball alumni thing and I was
downtown met this guy
happened to be a real estate investor
big-time investor and that Monday just
have this guy's number for the first
time hold him up and I said hey I got a
deal for you for you know forty eight
thousand dollars told the whole
situation me I need an answer ASAP heels
awesome I'm actually in Sioux Falls
right now going to take a look literally
thirty minutes later
I'll take before you the guy just met
two days prior yeah so like it we only
made you know we did we make that much
below yeah I was like wow sounds good
and then I got out of it yeah but see
here's what here's what took a turn
because that's where everything was
going pretty well and then that owner of
that deal his good friend solid he was
selling it and he contacted us and hey I
have a duplex I want to sell we go over
she accepted it for $28,000 and this is
the best deal I've ever come across
wait twenty thousand for a new plug yes
in where it was so it was like two
blocks east of east of like two Phillips
happen or whatever so like right word
developments coming and like the block
over had already gotten a letter this
year saying they can't sell that anybody
except its Sioux Falls cuz they're gonna
like terrible down so like this is
publication and it's a duplex $28,000
why was just gonna trying to sell
because this guy was it's all about
situation there was this guy situation
he needed some cash I don't know he's
trying to get out she's just trying to
get and this is the guy that sold his
house for forty five his friend his
friend actually while we're at that
house she actually drove up and said hey
about a full block we fit that in like
so he went to visit this guy's house and
I'm telling the best daughter came
across twenty thousand dollars a buyer
oh this hurts me so I got that we got
owner contracts on a Wednesday and I had
a buyer I'm gonna go look at it on a
Friday 3:00 p.m.
that's a buyer same buyer from Brooklyn
does the same guy same guy so I got
another one for ya more come down media
3:00 p.m. so about 2:30 I get an email
from the title company saying that there
is fifty three thousand dollars in liens
against that work that's why he was
doing it no no he didn't because the
only reason I email the title company
easy goes hey cuz he called buildings
like hey Dylan I just I just I think
there's a quite a few liens I totally
forgot this deal might not happen and I
was like don't worry about it would be
fine we'll figure it out
so you know them got it back here is how
there's one four thousand one through
six hundred one for nineteen thousand
one for 11,000 all of a sudden I'm like
what are those liens for they were like
judgmental means I don't even know I
think they were just like I'm you know
you get not a judgment what is it
judgment lien basically I think they
owed somebody money and then they took
him to like corn said hey this is
judgment and I put it against their
property to properties you're gonna say
yeah really I guess it's up to thirty
call up Brad the buyers coming off and
breaking his told the whole situation
she's like well I mean you want me to so
come take a look at it like I think you
could still get get out of that these I
think I've done that before I've you're
gonna get those liens down or whatever
so he comes down we look at it heals
well let me know if you if the liens
figure out so I'll pay forty four and uh
that's $12,000 I just heard say it
knowing how it's gonna work so we spent
like the next two weeks like trying to
get the trying to believe that we've got
him down to like 40 that's that's not
what it's not gonna work so that that
felt there right and similar Vanetta
partner fell through so those tough
those are great lessons these are great
lessons actually the coolest deal of a
guy we didn't wholesale was too good of
a deal
got it got a call on Friday this guy
from California like hey you know I got
a couple house in Kent's tota I got like
some hotels I need to sell yet I gotta
he had like a his main hotel burned down
in California because of like litigation
he wasn't getting all that money back
for a couple of years we needed to sell
all of his like South Dakota assets
long start short we got a ninety
thousand other house with $22,000 I
could have wholesale that for forty
right
at the close but I was like dude amazing
deal
brings in 850 a month I just I have my
dad I was like hey daddy what makes
money he loaned me $22,000 given ten
percent due when I sell it in 12 months
so there's no liens against it we own
this property free and clear and it
brings in 850 a month and the tenant
right now that's living in it and wants
to buy for ninety thousand when the
lease is up that's the best deal I've
came across this deal this house like
when I told somebody 54 only 22,000
because he the contingency was I needed
the thousand dollars in escrow the next
day and we needed to close in all cash
within ten days that's unheard of that
is unheard of ten day constant place
because guess what she said he turned
down he just got really turned on a 50k
offer because the guy couldn't close for
two months we said hey we'll give you
twenty two thousand will close in ten
days yeah which is that's before I asked
my dad I was like I'll file get away
from you I was like Dylan if you can
negotiate and get this for twenty two
thousand I will get the cash calls you
back yes sounds like dad we gotta talk
cute all about Thank You Lobby he's like
yeah she's like where was this property
it's in Casco that's so it seems like
it's can't stone up how far away is it
for me ah 30 minutes west their doom is
west of here it's kind of it's it's it's
tough that's what's past the mid note
before Mitchell right yeah good thing
about like single-family homes is like
they still kind of keep their value
because there's always gonna be a buyer
that's willing to you know they kind of
want you know whatever it's different
like if an apartment and Canastota
but yeah there was such a good deal I
had a couple buyers Roy hey like cooking
in 22 grand in cash for a property in
ten days that's the thing yeah yeah he
just wanted to move it as fast as
possible if any was trying to sell us
his freaking he had like a bunch of
motels in small towns he's trying to get
us to like she was giving us insane
deals on these motels and we were trying
to like sell them for him and by him but
nobody couldn't give us he could not
give us good enough numbers he couldn't
verify the expenses and income
kid was terrible yeah that all the
investors are just like we can do it but
we could have kind of unreal deals on
those too yeah so it's all about the
situation that's why it's that's cool
but I mean okay so all right let's let's
get that that's this last one so that we
have the bid for then total that this
one yeah that's about to close once the
tenant finishes his lease he's gonna buy
it the tenants gonna buy it yes we're
the own that one yeah but we're gonna
sell cuz it will yes you have to pay for
tax wise we don't want to sell it cuz he
buying right now but I don't want to
self twelve months to youth to pay 30%
tax oh okay so that's see that's one of
the see this is one of those little tiny
like anti in a sense it's like it's one
of those little rules and regulations on
capitalism that kind of makes it so that
you can't just buy a property and then
immediately sell it because you don't
have to pay 30 percent tax
exactly but I wonder if that's across
the nation or if that state by state is
is across the nation yeah well it's it's
it's the difference is long term for
short term capital gains but like the
only way you can get rid of paying taxes
is if you put put those proceeds
directly into another real estate
investment oh so so I get to keep moving
it forward you do yes you say I've made
a 70k profit yeah took 20 of it I'd have
to pay tax on 20 of it but the 50k can
go into another property and not pay any
taxes yeah so that's how that's why I
real estate school like if you can keep
rolling it forward yeah interesting yeah
so that's the capital gains tax of 30%
yeah so it's like flippers can't that's
why cuz think about like flippers
flippers would have to wait and renovate
a whole year they have to renovate away
yeah you can't 1031 within a year either
because then like think about it
flippers to like flip one tank they're
doing that and do another flip but like
they only like to do it if it's like
long term investments like apartments
okay okay okay so these have been the
successes than the failure you gave us a
couple examples of those awesome yeah we
did we I think we want to read photos we
didn't
close okay so then what's this whole
deal with the short and long-term
rentals what yeah what do you mean I'll
try to quickly Asiana quickly go through
this so I watch a lot of YouTube and I
was just wondering night I was just I
was doing something I had YouTube
playing wasn't really paying attention
and for some reason it this it caught my
attention this there was like this video
is Grant Cardone and a guy named Brian
Page and grant always like brings on
people like to talk about new things in
real estate and this guy was talking
about how literally he made it he'll
he'll manage other people's properties
put it on Airbnb forums with profit so
he started out where you know you go to
a you go to an apartment or say a house
in Phoenix
they're asking 2,000 a month say he'll
give you the 2,000 a month as long as
you let me rent without an Airbnb and
he'll make $5,000 a month so and he's
making he city at ten properties making
him like over 100k a month or like some
ridiculous numbers and I'm just thinking
like in my head like okay that's a
legitimate service that people could be
used so I was like that makes a lot of
sense but we were so busy with
wholesaling and like this apartment
stuff where I was like god I just can't
take on something else like it's just
too much I don't want to just half-ass
all these different things so I was like
how do I get somebody else or how do I
like execute this idea without like
disrupting that so I sent it to two good
my buddy two of my good buddies sent him
that exact video said hey what are your
thoughts both the mom within 30 minutes
it's a 26 minute video we're like holy
[ __ ] we got to do that so within two
weeks it was really lucky because my one
of the partners Mitch he was living in
this downtown Sioux Falls apartment that
for like two more weeks I think it was
like two more weeks at the time so we
wanted to try it out so he like took
everything out of this apartment it took
us like a whole day got this [ __ ] ready
learned everything about being the best
Airbnb host saw walking in five stars
and like we put it on the put it on
Airbnb for like seven nights we made it
available for seven nights than 24 hours
also tonight you're booked
and so we like went through that process
you know met with like check them in
Yatta Yatta it was actually it was Healy
definitely illegal to do that but we
can't want to get guy who was it
illegals because within the least you
can't do that within like Lisa's oh
because he was still be seeing it yeah
but it's funny because his cousin was on
the leaves and he was just kind of
living there for the summer because
cousin spoke we kind of wanted the the
apartment owner to come to us cuz gonna
be like hey I mean this how much money
we can do this for any of the other
safety yeah so we're like are this works
and then it quickly progressed to my
other partner Reid lives in Boca his
girlfriend has somebody that owns two
vacation homes down there asked if we
could do that for them and then another
one in Wisconsin this guy hit up one of
our friends the only person who knew we
were doing it somebody hit up her asking
if she could help him do that she sent
us we contact him so we're in the
process of those two because just
literally three weeks ago we started
whole thing and then just yesterday
Mitch went to visit to Sioux Falls lofts
downtown they were for rent and he was
just talking with the guy and the guy
said he just proposed it hey will you
let me do this if I pay you the fifteen
hundred a month in rent guy was all
about it we're waiting to hear back on
the contract details and we're gonna
just see if we can do it so it really
comes down to I think that's a
legitimate service because I talk to a
lot of people since then is people want
to stay in Metropolis is overnight or
even in cities in the downtown areas
night or two nights or three nights the
owners want something that like they
guarantee that you pay them every month
no matter what and so you're trying to
fill the rooms you also have to hire a
cleaning service to come in every one
night or every five nights or however
often people are coming into you have to
deal with the rating systems on Airbnb
and all that type of stuff so it is a
lot of work it provides a good service
for people it's understandable at the
same time it does in a sense we do have
to think about how a butterfly effects
out and affects other people as well
like literally if that guy at that
apartment complex was to be like oh my
we can make three times as much money
doing all of this on Airbnb
why would I have long-term year-to-year
tenants I should have do it all on
Airbnb if the market demands that and
then all he can fill all those units
then in a sense the question would be
what is actually more helpful for the
creativity or for the productivity or
for the or for just the overall
community as well of these areas is is
it that people can come through and be
creative or is it better if the long
term people are there trying to be
productive in the cities and communities
where are we stripping out the
communities from these cities and we're
just having people that come through
transiently over time just quickly so
that they can do just a quick
contribution so this is also complex in
terms of like economics community
creativity productivity it's very tough
to to get it all down but that's
probably why this recipe is so
complicated it'sit's and that's why it's
probably also so difficult to have a
nuanced conversation listing out all the
variables this is why I want to do a
like a center for economic simulation
like I care a lot about this idea like
what would it look like to make a
digital twin of the planet and then
actually be able to deploy like a
universal basic income to 300 million
Americans and model and like model what
would happen so that way you don't have
a bunch of people speculating or you
know what would happen or like a half a
percent tax on all Wall Street
transactions like what would happen to
the most wealthy people that have to pay
that tax and then where would that money
go and what would happen to the basic
needs of the people that need that money
could they live healthier and happier
lives at the expense of just a tiny
little percentage of Wall Street react
so this is a very interesting idea that
we're currently trying to pass along to
other friends that have work in the
simulation space to see if we can
actually move this forward the same
thing could be done to this example that
we're talking about with this loft space
in Sioux Falls like you could literally
simulate out the city of Sioux Falls and
what would happen in that is if the
owner did deploy all 30 of those lofts
whatever to Airbnb instead of long-term
tenants of what would happen to the
communities these are very interesting
questions yeah now you got me thing
about that stuff yeah the univer cooks
out of the year universal basic income
the problem with all those type of
things is that you rely on the
government to you're you rely on a
government to deploy that money that
they have correctly so are they going to
why why do we think they're gonna do it
correctly you know I mean that's my only
issue with it
this is like they might have the money
but are they gonna distribute it the
right way you know that's a whole nother
conversation but that's politics that's
politics Yankee bi yeah he's good yeah
yeah he's got some interest yeah that's
good yeah but what the Airbnb to wrap it
up yeah that's short and long term Brett
also wants to part of it just quickly
but once I start getting apartment
complexes instead of hiring out property
management companies I'm gonna create
that I'm gonna do it in-house and create
a separate arm
Medus no property management so that
like I can control the property
management because that's that the way
the way you win Apartments is they have
good property managers yeah so I'm gonna
make sure that they're good by creating
that company so that actually I haven't
actually built that yet but that's
that's that's a big key that's what the
long-term rentals management is so when
you guys get down to Tempe and Phoenix
you guys are gonna be doing you're gonna
be wholesaling real estate mostly down
done that that's the point I would say
yep it's gonna be a lot of wholesaling
hopefully try to get a couple houses we
can do Airbnb just to get some cat just
get that which will be short-term rental
short-term rentals and then it doesn't
really try and find our first department
deal our big goal in 29 2019 was to get
you know the wholesaling or whatever but
a big goal is get a 20 unit or higher
asset by the end of 2019 so we've
actually gotten closer that we've
thought but that's not so hopefully it's
still basically excuted it's basically
those three things management short-term
rentals wholesaling and then trying to
find
apartments so that's that's what the
companies do cool yeah yes this is been
a really solid update let's do let's do
some stuff around this I just you know I
mentioned this to you and your team just
a little bit ago over message we were
all talking about it it's just the
importance of turning what you're doing
into a media company we see it with
Grant Cardone and rights or huh well
sure yeah so you guys actually taking
and basically creating a log of your
experience a library of contents around
who you guys are what you're doing
make it making it really fun and
relatable for people to see okay maybe I
can do this around the world maybe I can
get inspired about this maybe I can get
out of the 9 to 5 and pursue
entrepreneurship through these means
maybe you can actually teach people
about how to deal with buyers sellers in
this title company and make it so that
when states where it's legal that people
can find their own wholesale deals and
you know it's actually interesting
because if this guy didn't have you the
one that I was trying to get in 10 days
just get the cash 22 grand he would have
been Sol for what he wanted to get done
[ __ ] out of luck
but guys we're there and so it's
interesting like people can get their
needs met yeah how many people like you
around which is also interesting so yeah
yeah but wait but you're but what you're
saying what you're saying is like right
like like the only reason we got that
deal is cuz we came across them online
but like what you're saying is like
getting stuff out there because I've
always wanted you can document the fact
that you did this deal this guy have it
on your YouTube and then you can
literally link that 10 minute video to
people that are to the next person that
calls you and says hey I need this
property I need to give you my private
50 K cash and you're like yo here's our
video I found you from this video
because you're my friend sent it to me
or whatever if here's my big thing on
that and the users I haven't done enough
then so so stupid you'll kind understand
I'm saying exacting I've talked about it
before I didn't want to do that because
I didn't want to be that guy who's like
bragging all this stuff but then like it
hit me it was like that's not bragging
you're literally just like showing
people what you're doing again literally
creating value are create all
doing you know I saw a couple real
estate people do that that their litter
just documenting what they do not try to
be counted literally just show you could
be over just showing you get to do I had
so much value for me it sounds like [ __ ]
like what I'm doing like me what me do
all like if we just showed you what
we're doing like someone's gonna get
value from that yeah so once I got over
that like just internal data like I
don't want to then I was like dude it's
it's no-brainer
exactly yeah so yeah I'm pumped started
in that for sure all right okay good and
then and then also another good one is
joining the conversations and as like a
cocktail party sound set of a
presentation party style so like the way
it is is like on Twitter if you're
looking up the hashtag real estate that
you can do things like to join people
what people are posting about it and
just say here's a really relevant
interview or video or vlog from our site
from our channel about what this thread
is currently talking about more people
hear about you more people will like and
retweet those posts and so the general
idea is that you don't just want to be
messaging tweeting directly from your
page and just saying hey everyone look
at what we're doing but you also want to
be joining all the conversations
happening every single hour about real
estate not only around the world locally
as well so like putting those two things
together is gonna be really critical at
your own YouTube channel and your own
social marketing strategies for cocktail
party style you're joining the party
instead of just presenting to people
yeah yeah it all comes down to being you
got to be in the digital age you got to
be good digital yeah yeah yeah you
probably obviously you learn a lot doing
that but it's it's interesting to you
know love being online it's fun to like
see like this awesome you it's gonna be
so critical for you guys to do this and
I can't it comes like this in our office
I was telling you so I'm so pumped throw
up yeah just throw up the camera and in
the little do stuff like this like and
just capture it that's right
yeah ask a grant how about um your
relationship with the divine with God's
or Spirit all that is what's been your
creation yeah so I you told me this is
gonna you kind of repairment to this
question didn't know what I've been
asking this question till almost all of
our guests really recently because I
think it's super
it's not enough people talk about this
and I don't really know how the way
you're gonna this is this kind of just
swear I think about the divine so I
think that everybody believes it's
something a higher power because if you
don't I mean it's I don't know I just
figure your life's gonna be I mean
that's tough yeah I believe it's
something's up there there's a higher
power I don't think there's any doubt
that there's a higher power and I think
all I think all the religions are just
different interpretations of that higher
power right but but my interpretation
I'm Christian and that's fine like I
believe in Christian Christianity but I
don't like to talk about it because I
don't know that I'm right I just know in
my is what I believe but at the same
time
I never say like Oh God did this to me
what I say is the universe tells a great
lesson from the universe because I like
to talk in terms of that because some
people a lot of people aren't they're
not religious but I feel like everybody
can relate to a higher power you know
the universe is happening for us so
that's me so I'm not a big and I'm a
Christian I believe in it but I'm not I
don't like to talk about it say that I'm
right cuz I just don't think there's not
a right religion yeah I hate when people
try to tell you that their religion is
right yeah because because don't you
think it's all interpretation of
themself in here that's what I if it's
all an interpretation of a higher power
yes and it's everyone's gonna have their
own unique communion with that higher
power yeah everyone has an own unique
experience and so it's not about my
communion is better than yours anyone
that starts talking like that it's not
actually it's not tough it's not ever
spiritually developed upper that it's
more becomes more about a breaking
process or about exerting power over
someone else and saying that your your
process is inferior your divine
communions inferior to mine so I'm glad
you say that and if we can see our lives
as a series of unleashing our gifts as a
channel having God or creation or desire
power come through us to help us bring
our gifts forth everything as lessons
we're gaining experience points you know
this game your these we were big gamers
we were younger that
literally gay gaining experience points
and we're gaining accolades and we're
leveling up we're defeating bosses
literally our literary game lifes again
if you think about the right way but
some people don't think of it as game
they don't they don't look for those
lessons then I look for those like we
are saying the universe comes together
if you look for it though
that sounds so hokey but it really isn't
you have to be a seeker you have to do
you have to like tell what you want and
then it you'll get it if you can it's
just given you in the morning and a
night instead of just rolling over and
grabbing your phone tap into your body
and your divine purpose and really try
and like really envision what your
successful future looks like and how
you're gonna achieve it and you'll see
more and more synchronicities going in
that direction because you're you're
catalyzing that process with the divine
versus when you're rolling over it's
succumbing to Alec I know it's not just
if you think about that's what I love
always talk to you because not that many
people get this deep about it and it's I
feel we're talking other people about
this stuff it's so true like like if you
think about like that like the amount of
people who don't have this mindset it's
like a superior spirit mind said it's
just I think it's the minds that you
should have but no well not that me
people have it it's like they don't
we're not about why the other option
that much either as and you have to know
that the other option exists when was
the last time that someone mentioned to
you hey hey you know that time that you
spend in that newsfeed you can actually
spend that time like creatively in the
hovering because you know there's just
like no when I'm there and I'm in line
or I'm just have my spare time like it's
immediate now that we just go to the
newsfeed so we need to know that the
other options exist like what would
happen if I just ask the person next to
me you know hey what's your name what's
your divine purpose in this world tell
me about who you are like what creative
lesson could come from that process I
can get better at socializing I can get
better at empathizing I can learn about
someone else's divine power but I have
to be willing to know that there's other
things on the tool belt and looking
[ __ ] newsfeed during that during that
little time that I agree I completely
agree and just just work to your point
about ask talk to people and asking good
questions and trying to like actually
get them to say something yeah I've done
that while lately like do you learn you
meet people you have better
conversations but like you feel like
they're happy to talk about it it's so
much nicer when you still when you get
them to talk about stuff that they like
they like so much better and Belov
talking about themselves but there's not
enough people that are out there asking
questions and willing to listen willing
to listen listen no one does that ask
questions be willing to listen everyone
I love that and something from Ed my lad
if something like this if you're like if
you're talking this is the first time
that you can tell it somebody's now
listening as if like as they're talking
like oh yeah for sure yep yep like it's
like they're like giving you a nudge to
like be done talking it's not yeah which
I never thought about like that but it's
like just listen to them and I'm like
now and then even if like after we're
done talking
give me two seconds see if they want to
add anything and then all right little
things like the happy in like I didn't
pull in a good interview skill most
people don't know about that one then
you've got to give an extra couple says
when someone finishes talking cuz they
always have follow-up video you know or
he comes up or something they were doing
the associative web in there and their
brain talking about it and then they
paused it looking at you and then all of
a sudden the brain still figure oh and
then they go and they go what the next
thing is that's the first I tried it the
next day and like right away I like it
feels weird in two seconds but they
almost always say something else yeah
beautiful also nonverbal communication
so just when someone's done talking just
look at them in eyes and just go like
you don't even need to say yeah you
don't even say words just literally
looking at them and being like you can
keep you you can give the look if I feel
you or that was dope or that was so
interesting by just looking at them you
know these are true there's a fact there
like most people don't know that the
reason why eyebrows exist is yes
we because of for being able to absorb
additional sunlight and blocking our eye
so that we can then see better so our
eyebrows contribute to that for people
also but people also strongly believe
that even more potentially percent of
the reason why we have eyebrows is for
nuanced facial expression so that oh
yeah or us yeah right so all of the
different eyebrow expressions you know
all the different things that you yeah
like that's yeah
there's millions of emotional
expressions that you can do without
using your voice yeah things like
absolutely but you have to be
appropriate with it obviously but like
you like things like like walking up
behind somebody like some talking about
grab on the shoulders actually I'm
talking about man we just like people
love that stuff but yeah like it's so
simple emotional intelligence I member
right when I like to learn about the
concept but that's it's all it is like
if you I mean how terrible is it when
somebody is just talking talking talking
talking talking about something they've
done it's like dude nice like you don't
want to be like a dick but it's like you
leave that conversation just really not
appreciating it we're not really wanting
to go hang out with them again that's
kind of what I feel but then like and
then when you do get in like
conversation like with you or somebody
else that has like you conversations
because a lot of people they don't even
know the concept of a conversation but
the people that do it's great like my
buddy Connor blows you I would I wish we
could hang out with him too because he's
one of those guys where every time I
hang out for my no we're gonna have a
good conversation which I know we're
gonna listen to each other talk about
good ideas but not that many people do
that so many people dude last night I
paved downtown it was that was great I
was just like dude I do not care cuz I
wasn't there I don't care about what you
did downtown I paid definite nothing
productive you don't want to say that
good see sound you come off you know you
did meet that Brookings guy at one of
those a right so that's another
interesting point in nuance because I'm
always frequently telling people there's
nothing really that productive at bars
or clubs or all that type of stuff any
of the old mind you gotta be somewhat
open line
type of stuff okay let's talk about
where do you think we come from do you
think that our spirit meets this body
for this lesson on the planet well I
mean I think we know how the body's made
but are not know these consciousness
know what it comes know where that comes
from do you think it emerges
biologically do you think that it
potentially comes and takes a seat in
the body the spirit or the soul comes
takes a seat in the body and then it
transitions you know pre-birth and
post-death it just goes back and
cyclical how do you think that I think
it so I got I don't I think that it I
think that it it comes it comes into us
from the higher power that's what I
think yeah that's what a lot of people
think but I have no idea I have no
reason to think that I'm right you have
no idea it's an interesting it is
because it could be because what do you
think the other side of it is that we
emerge from from the from the from the
ground from that from just like the
mostly nihilistic the most non-theistic
the most atheistic perspective is just
that we just this rock orbited the star
and we got lucky that it emerged in this
habitable zone and that we evolved from
single cell to multi cell life asteroid
came destroy the dinosaurs to make room
for us to evolve and it's just pure luck
and every single time that a
consciousness arises inside of a inside
of a body that it's just pure luck that
we're here and that it's just pure
biological process that consciousness
occurs here and then literally once you
die that's it nothing happens it's just
your consciousness died and that's it
there's no spirit there's no soul none
of that slight it's like once again so
like once you get pregnant as well as
they even think there's no higher power
they even think that this is like the
most extreme idea it's just that it
literally when you ask them a big big
bang there's like we have no idea but
big bang just happened and that's just
what this is it's just there's no higher
power but yet continue on the pregnancy
one that's that's the complete opposite
side of like there is a higher power
your solar sphere coming through these
yeah so like when you get pregnant then
like whatever goes is embryo whatever
goes there so like in those nine months
the consciousness girl is just out of
that just biologically that's okay
yeah the consciousness is a property of
information processing and I mean that's
the closest and some people say that
plants also do to literally if like a
bug takes a bite out of a plant the
plant will literally have a stress
response and so that's technically
information processing that the plant is
processing that the bug bit them and
that they now have to have a defense
mechanism to make sure that they don't
pass I can so people think that because
I mean there's obviously a reason people
think that it looks like their dog is
quite conscious but a plant is like oh
well the whole culture is a plant right
or the plant is pretty conscious they're
all conscious I that's what pants I kiss
believe is that everything is calm I
think everything's conscious yeah but a
lot of people they're all different
different consciousness levels yes and
what the most conscious does think see
that's a very interesting hubristic self
confident perspective on that it is
overly self-confident in a sense because
technically you look you do you look at
the kind of like you look at the inner
rhythm of a lot of other animals
especially like aquatic animals or just
even even like your household pets like
how much how interesting is that that
the way that the intelligence of
dolphins our bats are there's all these
other snakes there's things that can
like seeing infrared or use ultrasound
or all these types of things that we
don't have we do we haven't trained we
haven't evolved for those things they
Slyke some sleep I believe it's a
dolphin that's that's so sad see there
with half their brain yeah I'm so like
universe fear eclis sleeps with only one
side of their hemisphere sleeping and
the other side ira dolphins always fire
on us so and same with the octopi you
know all this type of stuff so
the so one of the one of the questions
is like what have humans actually
evolved our perceptional abilities
because right now it looks like our
perceptional abilities is pretty much -
like eat sleep reproduce and then work
and usually in working we're building
civilization but how often are we
training these faculties of like
communing with the divine on like a
normal basis like how good can you be at
communing with the divine to the point
where it's basically your second nature
to be tapped into a higher power all the
time every breath of air exactly the
example of like what do you mean up I
don't even know I don't know not like
your body right now you have like you
know your heart's beating a hundred
thousand times a day you're like you
know your autonomic submitters have
Scotch stuff like that type of stuff
even be really conscious of that type of
stuff and like you know your autonomic
nervous systems was helping you breathe
because you're not consciously going
right and so the idea is like can you
more consciously go can you more
consciously when you drink water or go
to the shower can you more consciously
be grateful for that water that's
sustaining you okay that's something you
something with your food that you eat
can you literally connect to the divine
before you eat your food interesting
yeah I don't really know yeah because
that's not its ability lies is our
possibility lies in that but we're so
overly consumed with what is just
mundane and repetitive for those who
don't for those who doubt to me to be
like scientific words I think basically
what you meant is like be grateful for
the little things just think in a more
basic basic way sure be great or at
least like like understand like ah that
water wants to be with my body you know
like yeah really small stuff little
small stuff yeah but there are also the
things that sustain us the most and
that's why people like these indigenous
tribes are on the planet are all saying
that it is our disconnection from nature
the fact that water sustains us food
sustains us the air sustains us of this
planet really this planet sustains us an
our disconnection from that process is
the reason why we're
crashing our planet and that's why we
have so many of the issues in our
civilization so literally if we could
heal our connection to the planet our
connection to this literally this thing
that sustains us that then that wisdom
would unlock our harmony with nature our
harmony with each other and solve so
many of the problems that we have
there's a lot of problem no that's
there's yeah there's there's a lot of
beautiful things but a lot of problems
let's see what yeah you're I wish I made
a lot of California a lot of people
think that way not enough people think
that way that's why you don't you don't
get that perspective up here is don't no
one talks about it yes it's there's a
losing more ways to dive into that it is
safe how about uh I don't think we asked
us lost them are we in a simulation and
so I think in some ways I mean we're in
a game I think we're in a game I play
like it's simulate no see this is all
right don't they it's simulation I don't
I don't know I think it's a game
someone's controlling it I mean [ __ ]
Christians if you're Christian he is in
the simulation you think about it
wouldn't be if you think Jesus and
everything they're controlling
everything aren't it aren't they the
creators of the simulation I don't know
I think I I look at I look at life as a
simulation where whoever is running it
is giving me options throw me off school
then kick them down seriously they like
it to me it's a game I don't know if
it's in I don't know if I don't know I
don't know if I'm gonna go all the way
to like Elon Musk's radical version of
the simulation but that's yeah tough
question and then what do you thinks the
most beautiful thing in the world I just
think the power to or I know it's a
beautiful thing is that you can always
you can do whatever you want you can
always change the story and there's no
limits and I think too many people put
limits on themselves and I just think
it's beautiful that if you really think
about it there's no limits and you can
tomorrow you can change your entire
story so I think I love that one like
it's very beautiful yeah
there's no limits an hour you can change
it seriously I don't give you a shitty
job [ __ ] quit figure it out you saw a
thing too many people like Tony
keyboards especially good if they
Emmeline if you don't have kids then it
got easier especially yeah and I just I
just hate the too many people playing
Victor the victim card I can't do this
like come on anyway
are you really living that two minds
that you whole entire life especially
when you're on your deathbed and you're
like oh my god never learned Who I am I
don't know who I am or that do I work to
like yeah then in that kind of stuffing
that's abscess real I mean it's real you
think what that plagues our society
people don't get to unlock their gifts
and bring them to the world absolutely
we need to help children do that as fast
as possible more effectively actually
what [ __ ] awesome round spirit combo
super fun last time I didn't know we
were gonna do since I was pumped all day
for it a good bro okay we got all the
equipment - oh yeah we have the
equipment this time I love it thanks
everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciated we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on our
conversation yep absolutely not us know
what you're thinking about real estate
in general let us know what you're
thinking about real estate investing
these is this idea of finding off market
properties real estate wholesaling
managing short and long term rentals and
also apartments indications let us know
what you're thinking about those things
go and have more conversations to your
friends families co-workers people
online on social media about these
topics as well about everything from
also rent seeking capitalism all the way
to understanding how to create a better
social fabric for unleashing people's
gifts all these great topics check out
the links in the bio below to meta stone
capcom as well as we buy home sue falls
calm and the top tier mg calm as well
find all those links below and also
support the artists the entrepreneurs
the spiritual leaders organizations in
your communities that you believe in
support them and help them grow support
simulation our links are below you can
find our patreon crypto-currency paypal
links down below as well as they're
designed cool merch you get paid all its
stuffs in the links below
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in we'll see you soon have a good night
peace peace
[Music]